sort of on a on a more philosophical
level I think we're going to have to
figure out how we're going to deal with
change and the pace of change one of the
things i've really noticed as a
scientist over the last 20 years i think
is is that as scientific and engineering
advances occur they are always
accompanied by anxiety on the part of
the public about the degree to which
those advances as wonderful as some of
them may be in terms of saving lives or
improving the quality of life they bring
change and change is hard and i think it
is going to be a real challenge to
manage that change in a way that does
not exacerbates or the overall level of
anxiety that exists around things like
stem cells and around internet privacy
for example all legitimate things to be
concerned about but but anxiety that's
getting in the way with having that
technology actually have the positive
impact is capable of having